sandra what's up i was hoping that you
could help me uh
with some grief
tactics or methods perhaps
um so in 2018 my family had a
pretty lousy year starting oh this would
be bad for me hold on one second
hey you're good you're good
so starting with my son's my adult son's
um heroin overdose oh man i'm so sorry
yeah and then then i lost my dad
to advanced dementia in may
and then my younger brother in december
died suddenly
but that really the i struggle the most
with
my the situation with my son
tell me about him well he um
he had a difficult life so he
as a heroin addict he would often make
bad decisions and spent a lot of time
in and out of jail so we
so my process i feel like i've been
grieving for
or maybe grieving incorrectly for
12 15 years at least
so he um you know it's things like uh
every holiday yeah but even while he was
alive of course
it's like well he's in jail so
he's not experiencing this um
so i just surround myself with guilt
yeah and you beat yourself
up for who he was as a young boy and the
situations that happened in his life and
yeah then the the missed dinners that
turned into the missed holidays it
turned into the jail time which turned
into
yep the ultimate prize so first and
foremost
um i'm heartbroken for you people aren't
supposed to have years like 2018
and i know it's probably insulting to
you to hear all the people whining about
2020 myself included right
and i know for you you can think
you guys want me to tell you about a bad
year right um
that's that's a lot you lost
what i would be willing to wagers the
three of the most important men in your
entire life right
yeah yeah
what did what did grieving look like
with him what the funeral looked like
what did the the circumstances
surrounding that look like
well probably the start of a of a bad
process i would say
as you can imagine i don't deal with
these things very well
based on this conversation but uh you're
doing great
oh thanks well we so we did a private
uh service with just the immediate
family yeah
and you know i don't i didn't want
i first of all i didn't i don't know
friends i mean i don't know
people i didn't know people to contact
and
and things like that for him and then
for us
you know our outside circle of friends
and associates and things
um i just couldn't do a day of
handling
it was hard to you didn't want to answer
questions and have to
do the reception line and yep yep
exactly
so it was just it was just immediate
family
so sandra um this is going to be either
easier said than done
but you've got to stop judging yourself
you've got to stop being ashamed of the
person your son was
yeah right and i know every single mom
the moment they hold that little baby
boy they
have man i've listened to my wife fast
forward
you know in year one i hope i like his
wife and i'm like what
right and i think we're gonna have the
wedding and you're like
we we gotta slow the roll right um
i know that every mom holds that little
baby and
just a narrative unfolds right a story
unfolds and
it is really hard when every morning you
wake up here we are two years three
years later
and that story is not gonna happen right
it's not gonna come true
the more you avoid putting a period at
the end of that story
the more you continue to carry those
bricks of
i failed as a mom my son was a failure
as a guy as
long as you hold that shame that
identity
as a grieving mom it's going to beat you
up spiritually and psychologically
your health is gonna suffer from that
and i want you to know
you're worth more than that oh thank you
you don't believe that but i'm telling
you and i want you just to
get on youtube or listen to this podcast
over and over and just hit
refresh refresh on that you are worth
grieving this you're worth holding your
head high and you are worth living the
rest of the years that you've got
left boldly and unapologetically
and with the new spirit of meaning about
it okay
no you bet you bet and do all of us wish
we could take things back
as if from our kids childhood yep right
and so those things that may have
happened that you think through that pop
into your head
here's what i want you to do i want you
to consciously
whether you've got to say out loud and i
have to do this to myself sometimes
when that thing that conversation that
you had when you were a kid or that
thing that happened where you when he
was young and you wish you could have
done it differently or
your husband said this one thing and you
sh i want you just to
if you have to yell it but just say
stop right say it out loud
nope because at this point moving
forward i want you to
to consider those intrusive thoughts
those
shameful moments those well if you'd
only thoughts
i want you to say no i want you to
listen to the i mean i want you to know
those are now decisions from this point
forward
and focusing on those won't help your
son
focusing on those won't help heal your
heart
they're just going to keep you chained
to the shame and shame to the
chained to the past right yeah
so you said something earlier that i i
really want to lean on and i want you to
listen to me closely okay
okay there is no such thing as an
incorrect way to grieve something other
than not grieving at
all and this is
three years two and a half years you're
getting up right you're about a month
and a half away two months away you're
getting up on
the third anniversary and it's gonna
those little anxiety bells are gonna
start ringing louder and louder remember
remember right
and then you're gonna enter what i would
probably assume is gonna be a dark
season
when your body remembers 2018
right one loss after another loss after
another loss there
is not an incorrect way to grieve that
other than to shove it down and act like
it's not happening
okay so here's a couple of things that
i've walked alongside folks that they've
found helpful in the past that i've
found helpful in the past
number one you cannot cannot under
any circumstances sandra grieve by
yourself
okay so this is the time and i know it's
super annoying and hard with govid
especially in the city like chicago
you've got to find somebody
a small group an individual a counselor
somebody that you can say out loud i'm
not going to be ashamed of my son
anymore
i'm gonna choose to remember the great
good stuff about him he probably had a
sweet sweet soul
i'm gonna remember the joy and fun that
we had when he was younger
i'm just not gonna focus on the negative
stuff because it doesn't do anybody any
good
and i want you to experience that
vulnerability
and that shame letting i want you've got
to do that with somebody else
okay that's going to be vulnerable
moment number one for you
vulnerable moment number two is i want
you to write him
a letter that tells him about what in
the craps going on in 2021 and that you
miss him like crazy
i want you to write him a second letter
possibly with this person right and i
want you maybe you read it to this
person
if you're super hardcore and vulnerable
and tough
i want you to write him a second letter
and tell him that you're heartbroken
that he left you
okay because it's okay to be angry with
him it's okay to be
frustrated with him it's okay to be
really really pissed off at him
and then the third letter i want you to
write him
and tell him um who you're becoming
but i want you to write it as though you
want him to know how proud of
you he should be because you're going to
be the mom who now you're going to go
take dance lessons once they
the lockdown is over and you're going to
learn spanish
and you're going to start delivering
meals on wheels you are going to start
living this shame free this
unfettered life that's not going to be a
forgetting of him
not going to be forgetting your dad not
even forgetting your brother but it's
going to be in celebration up it's going
to be meaning making of
and when you get a group and you spend
some hard hard minutes writing these
letters to them
uh to your to your son and they don't
have to be all the same day especially
shouldn't be on the same day
when you do this what's gonna start to
happen is you're gonna start to smile
you're going to start to heal a little
bit
you're going to have good days you have
real bad days and on the bad days i want
you to go
well that's my body trying to take care
of me again i want you to smile those
days and then get back under the covers
if you need to
and if you got to go to work you got to
get up and that's where you're going to
reach out to your buddies and to your
friends because you can't do this alone
and over time you're going to begin to
make meaning here
and what making meaning looks like is
different for everybody
it may be you joining a group to go talk
to young boys who are getting into drugs
it may be you writing letters to young
addicts
in jail and letting them know that hey
their mama loves them
and that you will be there when they get
out
it may be that you're going to help nit
and cross i don't know what i don't know
what you do you may
you may build machine guns there i don't
know what you do but you're going to be
making
meaning for the rest of your life
sounds like a good idea but here's the
all of this is under one giant shell
which is this
you have to decide i'm not gonna wear
the identity
i'm not gonna consider myself a failed
mom
i'm not gonna consider myself somebody
who's just grieving for the rest of
their life
is the ache of the loss of your son
always going to be there dang right it
is he was your baby boy
but that's not going to define you
you're going to have to let that go and
letting that go is going to feel like
you're letting him go
yeah okay and you are going to have to
moment where you have to have a moment
where you let him go and that's when you
get to
live in those joy the however few they
are however many they are
that's when you get to live in those
joyful joyful moments
so i wouldn't wish 2018 that you
experience on anybody
even people i can't stand being around
that's heavy and hard heavy and hard
i'm sorry to experience that if you want
to be real brave sandra
when you get a chance when you write one
of those letters i'd love for you to
call it in and read it out on the show
i think that would be healing for
millions of people who are experiencing
disconnection from their kids
who are are heartbroken over you know
children who've made choices that they
don't agree with that are
locked them up all those struggles i
think that'd be a beautiful beautiful
moment um
that's hard though that's really hard
you don't have to do that but man that
it would be a blessing
thank you so much for that call sandra
we love you and we care about you